hello everyone welcome to
don't just take this stupid thing off
i've just been out saving people as iron
man
uh welcome to the kevin spoiler show i'm
your host kevin spoilers
i've been working all day from about
half six in the morning till
till half five now uh in england and i
was just about to sit down and have my
tea but then they announced this story
that chris evans is returning to the mcu
as captain america
so naturally just threw the plate across
the room like it was captain america
shield
ran upstairs told the wife i said forget
it
youtube's more important to me than our
relationship and sat down
and we're gonna go through this story
here and i'm gonna give my thoughts on
it
now there's been a lot of rumors
floating about in the ether that robert
downey jr is returning to the mcu in
some form or another
not sure how legitimate they are but you
know chris evans with him being in talks
to come back
it sort of adds a lot of weight to that
disney at the moment are clearly like
you know
we need to get something in place just
so old fans don't leave
and it looks like they're starting to
talk people back around now according to
the report
which i'm gonna read for you very very
lazy content look i've been working all
day yeah
in a move that is sure to rock the
marvel cinematic universe
sources tell deadline that chris evans
is cleaning the dust off his captain
america attire
as he's expected to reprise the role in
the mcu in some form
according to report it's very vague as
the deal's not closed but
insiders say that he's headed in a
direction that he's going to return for
at least one marvel property
and the doors open for a second film so
yeah lots lots of things going on there
um they they say here mention it could
be something similar to how robert
downey jr did uh
spider-man homecoming marvel had no
comment which
means we can't confirm at the moment and
you know evans in general has kind of
been like
well if the doors open if they want me
back i'm coming back up captain america
now this of course opens you know up
there there's so many stories that you
can tell we we obviously had the disney
invest today
uh last month seems like a year ago
which
it actually was uh and kevin feige and
that went through things like secret
invasion which could open the door to
secret wars um or it might be in secret
wars which could open the door to secret
invasion
but either way he could fit into that
now personally
by the sounds of it with it being a sort
of robert downey jr and spider-man
homecoming
i'm guessing that that means he might
appear on falcon in the winter soldier
in some form down the line
like obviously the the first season has
been filmed i kind of feel like he's
going to make a cameo in that as
i think it would just be very weird for
falcon at the end of the movie to be
like
well thanks for the shield i'm off i'll
see you later so maybe he'll appear as a
sort of mental role
similar to what robert downey jr did in
spider-man 3
spider-man homecoming sorry but the door
is definitely open there for him to do
a lot of different things with the
character now the one more film
i'm actually you know i'm a bit
interested about this because
i i think there's such a big time period
from the
the last scene of end game up to when
he's an old man
and by that i mean you know we know he
travels back in time and returns all the
stuff the infinity stones to their
rightful place
there was obviously along the way some
confrontation with red skull that we
never got to see
and personally i would absolutely love
to see that on the big screen
i'm not too interested in the whole
captain america joe biden thing i know
he impeached trump and beat him in the
election but
the old guy there's only so much that
you can really do with him
uh you know maybe give give falcon uh
where there's original say can i have my
shield back just kidding
got your nose and beyond that there's
not really much that he can do with that
so personally i think
that they should kind of go back a bit
show us that journey which is very very
interesting
and of course you can have red skull is
the villain in that no one really knows
what happens to him once the soul stone
gets taken
and it could be possible that he's set
free as this one task that he's been
assigned to has been completed
and i would absolutely love to see evans
in red skull going head-to-head in
something like that
now we're kind of theorizing here but
we'll read the report first before we do
any more of that
um so evans has become more game to the
idea with
more apparently him and marvel or rather
his agents coming to an agreement
at the start this year how he may return
is still unclear and being worked out
but the options are unlimited
over the years even after a character's
film franchise has come to an
end marvel has found a way to insert
them into every single mcu property
no robert downey jr we need you back i
don't care if you're dead
um so yeah they're just kind of saying
they don't know whether he's gonna be in
a disney plus show or if it'll be a film
whatever the path may be though fans are
sure to be invigorated
knowing that they could be seeing the
return of a character that they assumed
wouldn't be back anytime
soon now personally i actually really
like the ending that captain america got
having him dance with peggy um and then
sort of looking back on his life
remembering the good old days
and kind of keeping that thing to
himself when when falcon was like
kev did why didn't are you going to stop
9 11 in the past and he's like
nope don't think i will and i really
really thought that was a great way to
take the character the thumbs down
buttons right there and for that joke by
the way i'm very sorry
but yeah it was kind of a nice closing
of the chapter
and if they do bring him back i want it
to really be something special
now obviously there's going to be so
many things that we can take from this
the deal isn't confirmed no matter what
anyone says deadline are simply just
saying
this is still open at the moment but it
is looking like things are going to be
going ahead
now chris evans obviously this is one of
the biggest jobs he's ever
probably it is the biggest job he's ever
had let's be honest
it's avengers end game was the the
highest grossing movie of all time
and to turn that down you know
i personally would be like yeah i'm
gonna be in it too
just put me in anything so the doors are
open
um by the sounds of it he's going to be
a sort of mental figure which i think
would make it
sort of makes sense that he's tied in
with falcon in the winter soldier
but again they could show that journey
where he disappeared into the past now
this is the time that i want to hear
from you guys so obviously
leave your comments below apologies for
the the very
short and kind of crushed together video
i know
that this isn't usually the quality that
you're used to getting
but it's been a long day and i'm i'm
preparing for one division tomorrow
which i hope you're as excited for as i
am now leave your comments below i'd
love to hear them and if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of all the
news on spider-man 3 which is going to
be linked on screen in a second
thanks for bearing with me through this
report and yeah hype hype hype
i'll see you next time take care peace
you